or the 2nd of january is when
communities in cape town take to the
streets ushering in the new year the
musicians and dancers are part of klopsa
or clubs they bang gumma drums creating
the unique sound and rhythm singing
songs of hope and good luck often taking
pop songs and making it their own
it's a mind-blowing experience it's
mind-blowing you cannot imagine
people start to fly
the music drives them me more
give me more and everyone was saying
give me more
[Music]
malvin has been part of these parades
since he was a child
some of his earliest memories go back to
the 1950s and 60s freedom that's
experienced
in the parade
but there's much more than
than what what people can imagine
the carnival goes back more than 200
years when the dutch colonized the cape
in what is today south africa
slaves would come out on the second day
of the new year to celebrate the day off
it's evolved since then while the first
formal carnival was held in 1907.
this is book up in cape town where the
parade of musicians and dancers would
pass through surrounded by tens of
thousands of people who've come out to
watch the spectacle but for a second
general covert 19 has interrupted this
long-standing tradition
despite the event being cancelled some
troops continue to practice whenever
covert 19 restrictions are eased
this is just one of the dozens of clubs
that participate with more than 20 000
other musicians dancers and singers
people are devastated there's very very
very little that that we have going for
ourselves we come from the most
marginalized part of of society here at
the at here in the western cape um
the attitude really is that we need to
get the carnival going as as quickly as
possible
while the carnival's origins go back to
the days of slavery people in this
community say it now symbolizes far more
we utilize
to drive us forward into the new year
and and we use it as an aspirational
factor right we become positive again
positive after a year of strife
for now the usual celebrations have been
put on hold but still with the hope that
the global pandemic will not derail the
passing on of a centuries-old custom
family al jazeera cape town